el principio de incertidumbre de
heisenberg es un principio de la
mecánica cuántica y él nos dice
esencialmente que si tomamos una
partícula digamos digamos que tenemos
una partícula aquí y esta partícula
tiene una masa m y se mueve con cierta
velocidad ve muy bien tenemos esta
partícula entonces el momento lineal de
esa partícula es igual a la masa por la
velocidad verdad y de acuerdo a nuestro
principio de incertidumbre no podemos
decir la posición y el momento de esa
partícula de forma precisa al mismo
tiempo muy bien así que si sabemos la
posición puedes decir si sabemos dónde
se encuentra la partícula en el espacio
de forma muy precisa entonces no sabemos
cuál es su momento o bien es equivalente
a decir que no sabemos cuál es la
velocidad de esa partícula y viceversa
si sabemos cuál es el momento de forma
muy precisa entonces no podemos conocer
la posición así que vamos a fijarnos en
una descripción matemática del principio
de incertidumbre
así que el principio de incertidumbre
nos dice que por ejemplo si consideramos
la incertidumbre en la posición y que
vamos a denotar lo como delta x muy bien
entonces delta x es la incertidumbre en
la posición esto al multiplicarlo por la
incertidumbre del momento ok del tape
sería la incertidumbre en el momento
entonces el producto de estos dos debe
ser mayor o igual que la constante una
cierta constante que es la constante de
planck dividida entre 4 y así que en
resumen lo que tenemos es una constante
dividida entre una constante lo que
tenemos del lado derecho esencialmente
es un número y quizás podrías ver
algunas cosas un poquito distintas
dependiendo el libro de texto que estés
utilizando en realidad no importa mucho
simplemente depende de cómo estemos
definiendo las cosas el punto aquí es
que el producto de estas dos
incertidumbres debe ser mayor o igual
que cierto número verdad que es cierto
así que las incertidumbres son
inversamente proporcionales la una con
respecto a la otra verdad si
incrementamos una entonces tendré
tendremos que disminuir la otra así que
vamos a continuar utilizando algunos
números muy simples aquí para que
podamos comprender el punto de este
principio así que digamos no sé para
algún caso sumamente simplificado
digamos que tenemos que la incertidumbre
para la posición vale 2 muy bien eso
sería la incertidumbre para la posición
y digamos que tenemos una incertidumbre
para el momento que también vale 2
verdad y pongamos que esto es igual a 4
olvidémonos por un momento que es mayor
o igual a 4 digamos que es exactamente
igual a 4 muy bien así que si
disminuimos la incertidumbre de la
posición digamos si lo disminuimos a 1
aquí tenemos la incertidumbre ahora vale
1 entonces la incertidumbre en el
momento debe aumentar a 4 verdad para
que sigamos manteniendo esta misma
constante que fuera 4 verdad porque 1
por 4 sería 4 y 2 por 2 es 4 verdad
entonces si disminuimos la incertidumbre
del de la posición a 1 entonces la
incertidumbre del momento tiene que
aumentar a 4 verdad ahora bien si
nosotros disminuyen amos todavía más la
incertidumbre de la posición digamos que
fuera 0.5 entonces la incertidumbre del
momento tiene que aumentar nuevamente a
8 verdad porque 0.5 por 8 es igual a 4 y
en esencia lo que estoy tratando de
demostrar aquí es que si disminuimos la
incertidumbre de la posición entonces
tendremos que aumentar la incertidumbre
del momento o bien otra forma de decir
esto mismo es que mientras más mientras
conozcamos de forma más precisa la
posición de una partícula sera
menos precisa el conocimiento del
momento de esa misma partícula verdad y
esa es la idea del principio de
incertidumbre así que vamos a aplicar
este principio de incertidumbre al
modelo de por qué y aquí tenemos el
modelo de board para el átomo de
hidrógeno verdad aquí tenemos una imagen
de el modelo de board para este átomo de
hidrógeno muy bien así que nosotros
sabemos que tenemos una carga eléctrica
negativa verdad que esencialmente es un
electrón que está orbitando alrededor
del núcleo justamente como un planeta
orbita alrededor del sol verdad y
digamos que este electrón va en esta
dirección la cual nos dice que lleva
cierta velocidad ve correcto ahora bien
la razón por la cual el modelo de board
es útil es porque nos permite entender
cosas como por ejemplo los niveles
energéticos cuántica 2 y ya hemos
hablado por ejemplo del radio de del
electrón así
si por ejemplo aquí tenemos este este
círculo aquí entonces tenemos un radio
hacia el electrón tenemos un radio hacia
el electrón del primer nivel de energía
que es igual a 5.3 por 10 a la menos 11
metros
así que si quisiéramos conocer el
diámetro de ese círculo entonces
simplemente tendríamos que multiplicar
el radio por 2 verdad así que dos veces
este radio sería más o menos bueno más o
menos sino sería 1.06 por 10 a la menos
menos 10 metros verdad simplemente
multiplicamos 5.3 por 2 y recorremos el
exponente del 10 muy bien simplemente
para que quede en notación científica y
esto es simplemente una estimación un
poco burda del tamaño del átomo de
hidrógeno utilizando el modelo de boro
un electrón en el primer nivel de
energía verdad ahora bien la velocidad
de ese electrón en el primer nivel de
energía de un átomo de hidrógeno
utilizando este mismo modelo de board se
ha calculado que es 2.2 por 10 a las 6
metros sobre segundo y de hecho también
conocemos la masa de un electrón verdad
la masa de un electrón sería esta y con
esto podríamos calcular el momento
lineal así que el momento lineal sería
simplemente la masa por la velocidad y
digamos que conocemos la velocidad con
una incertidumbre del 10 por ciento
aunque conocemos la velocidad pero con
verdad entonces el 10 por ciento en
realidad corresponde por ejemplo si lo
convertimos a un decimal sería igual a
dividir 10 entre 100 verdad así que el
10 por ciento es igual a punto
punto 10.1 es lo mismo así que si
queremos conocer la incertidumbre del
momento de dicho electrón entonces la
incertidumbre del momento de dicha
partícula sería igual a la masa la masa
la masa por la velocidad por la
incertidumbre que en este caso sería
punto uno muy bien pero nosotros
conocemos muy bien cuánto es la masa
sería 9.11 por 10 a la menos 31 que
multiplica a la velocidad la velocidad
es 2 puntos 2 por 10 a las 6 y luego
simplemente multiplicamos por punto 1
así que vamos a hacerlo vamos a hacer
esas cuentas muy bien tendríamos 9.11
aquí abrimos un paréntesis sería 10
elevado a la abrimos un paréntesis más
menos 31 muy bien y vamos a cerrar los
paréntesis tendríamos serían perdón es
9.11 verdad 9.11 y por 10 a la menos 31
y eso hay que multiplicarlo por 2.2 y
multiplicamos por 10 elevado a la
volvemos a abrir otro paréntesis a las 6
y cerramos nuestros paréntesis muy bien
y hasta ahí va esto que si lo podemos
ver en notación científica sería 2.000
42 10 a la menos 24 y luego esto lo
multiplicamos por punto
y eso nos da 2.0 por 10 a la menos 25
muy bien entonces tendríamos que esto es
2.0 por 10 a la menos 25 y las unidades
es muy simple porque la masa es
kilogramos y la velocidad es metro sobre
segundo así que las unidades quedarían
como kilogramos por metro sobre segundo
muy bien así que esta es la
incertidumbre asociada con el momento de
nuestro electrón verdad así que esto lo
podríamos meter justamente al principio
de incertidumbre
teníamos que el principio de
incertidumbre nos dice que en la
incertidumbre de la posición
multiplicada por la incertidumbre del
momento lineal debe ser mayor o igual
que la constante de planck dividido
entre 4 y verdad entonces lo que podemos
hacer es introducir esta cantidad en
el principio de incertidumbre de
heisenberg y ahora podríamos estimar la
incertidumbre en la posición del
electrón verdad en el primer nivel del
átomo de hidrógeno verdad así que vamos
abajo bajar un poco
tendríamos que la incertidumbre en la
posición multiplicada por esta cantidad
que sería 2 puntos 0 por 10 a la menos
25 tiene que ser mayor o igual que la
constante de planck que equivale a 6.6
25 por 10 a la menos 34 dividido entre 4
pi y esto lo podríamos resolver
digamos podríamos estimar la
incertidumbre de la posición verdad y
podemos hacer las cuentas de nuevo en
nuestra calculadora sería 6.6 25
abrimos paréntesis 10 elevado a la
abrimos paréntesis menos 34 cerramos
todos nuestros paréntesis y eso nos da 6
puntos 6 25 por 10 a la menos 34 eso ya
lo sabíamos y hay que dividir esto entre
4 verdad y después dividimos entre pi y
eso nos da la cantidad del lado derecho
ahora para para resolver en términos del
de la incertidumbre de la posición hay
que dividir entre esta cantidad que es
la incertidumbre del momento lineal así
que hay que dividir todo eso entre 2 x
abrimos paréntesis 10
es elevado a la - al menos 25 muy bien y
cerramos nuestros paréntesis
y eso nos da digamos redondeando sería
2.6 por 10 a la menos 10 verdad entonces
esto sería igual a 2 puntos
bueno pondríamos así la incertidumbre de
la posición es mayor o igual que 2.6 por
10 a la menos 10 metros verdad tendría
que ser metros porque es una posición
así que la incertidumbre de la posición
es mayor o igual que 2.6 por 10 a la
menos 10 metros así que si regresamos a
nuestra imagen que teníamos por acá
entonces podemos observar que dos puntos
bueno en realidad teníamos dos puntos
seis por diez a la menos diez metros
supera por mucho o bueno quizás más o
menos por el doble al diámetro de
nuestro átomo de hidrógeno según el
modelo de vor así que la incertidumbre
en la posición es más grande de hecho
quizás debería ponerlo algo así es más
grande que el diámetro del átomo de
hidrógeno según el modelo de board y eso
nos sugiere que el modelo de board está
mal verdad nos está diciendo que el
electrón está orbitando alrededor del
núcleo verdad a cierto radio y se mueve
a cierta velocidad el principio de
incertidumbre nos dice que eso no es
cierto verdad que de hecho si conocemos
la velocidad de forma muy precisa
entonces no podemos conocer la posición
del electrón verdad nosotros tenemos que
la incertidumbre de la posición del
electrón es mayor que el diámetro verdad
y de acuerdo al modelo
de voz así que esta es una de las
razones por las cuales el modelo de voz
está mal pero nuevamente seguimos
estudiando el modelo de board porque es
muy útil como un modelo simple sobre
todo cuando estamos empezando a
introducirnos a la química verdad pero
este concepto del principio de
incertidumbre va en contra de nuestra
intuición natural verdad nuestra nuestra
intuición del día a día en realidad no
nos dice eso verdad no no tenemos una
experiencia con el principio de
incertidumbre por ejemplo si tuviéramos
no sé una partícula hagamos una
partícula un poco un poco más grande que
el electrón o quizás mucho más grande
que el electrón aquí tenemos esta
partícula y digamos que esta partícula
tiene una masa m que sea mucho más
grande que la del electrón y tenga
cierta velocidad ver en entonces la
lógica nos dice que podríamos calcular
de forma muy precisa donde se encuentra
la posición de ese objeto y seguramente
podríamos calcular de forma muy precisa
cuál es su velocidad y por lo tanto
podríamos conocer
su momento verdad y de hecho así es como
lo hemos hecho en otros cursos por
ejemplo en física o cosas del estilo en
realidad nosotros conocemos de forma muy
precisa
ambas ambos ambas cosas no la posición y
el momento pero por ejemplo si usáramos
un cálculo por usando el principio de
incertidumbre así que digamos que vamos
a poner números distintos digamos que
incrementamos la masa iu y digamos que
en lugar de 9.11 por 10 a la menos 31
tuviéramos 9 kilogramos y digamos que
introducimos en esta ecuación no sea
alguna velocidad de este de este lado y
si resolvemos para la incertidumbre de
la posición vamos a obtener una
incertidumbre en la posición que es
realmente pequeña así que realmente no
no notamos este tipo de cosas en una
escala macroscópica simplemente las
podemos notar cuando estamos hablando de
una escala microscópica es decir para
masas sumamente pequeñas y eso es por lo
por lo que es un concepto
no es muy intuitivo verdad y en realidad
es la misma idea con la mecánica
cuántica la mecánica cuántica es algo
que absolutamente no no tiene sentido la
primera vez que que uno se encuentra
porque no tenemos experiencia con la
mecánica cuántica en el día a día en la
vida cotidiana simplemente parece no
tener sentido no vemos este tipo de
cosas verdad esto simplemente nos está
mostrando una aplicación en una escala
atómica nuevamente este es el principio
de incertidumbre y vamos a introducirnos
un poco más en la mecánica cuántica y
veremos en los próximos vídeos cómo es
que la mecánica cuántica afecta
electrones y átomos